bonjour C'est lundi
[Musique]
au premier édition un peu fait la fête
vendredi soir et certains conservent des
stigmates
on est très content de vous retrouver
vous avez bien dormi cette nuit pas trop
c'était terrible et des températures
hier mais c'était vraiment comme on dit
une chaleur claviculaire
je comprends pas les gens moi qui vont à
la plage se faire rôtir bêtement après
ils prennent des coups de soleil ils
attrapent des cancers c'est stupide
éventuellement tu vas te baigner vite
fait en fin d'après mais tu restes pas
et tu es pas obligé de descendre avec ta
Rolex ton ton enceinte portable
capter téléphone etc etc tu es pas
obligé d'aller tous te baigner en même
temps par exemple
dans la bagnole et tu fais un peu
attention les gens sont benés aussi
c'est ça le problème pour nettoyer son
image la célèbre marque de face fashion
Shein fait appel à des influenceurs en
visite dans l'une des usines à gongzu en
Chine un voyage qui a changé ma vie Dany
Carbonari suivi par près de 500 000
personnes a ainsi fait l'éloge du géant
de la mode un soutien aveugle qui passe
sous silence les multiples violations
des droits du travail
en vacances là
en revanche là ce que je vois vient
gâcher mon arrivée c'est quoi ce bazar
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible
tout est empilé non mais qu'est-ce que
c'est que cette décharge
là c'est une première
je suis heureuse de savoir que des gens
formidables fabriquent les vêtements que
je porte et qu'ils sont tout aussi
passionnés par leur travail que moi des
enquêtes médiatiques avaient pourtant
révélé que les ouvriers de Chine
travaillaient jusqu'à 75 heures par
semaine avec seulement un jour de congé
par mois
le déplacement d'Emmanuel Macron dans la
ville dont il adopte l'accent dès qu'il
s'y trouve
la suggestion du ministre de l'Intérieur
à Monsieur le Maire que nous finantions
[Musique]
2021 de cette nouvelle visite
présidentielle sur le vieux port les
Marseillais n'auront pas vu grand chose
tenue à distance à 400 mètres de la
mairie pas franchement la meilleure
entrée en matière pour se déplacement
son peuple entre guillemets voilà le 10
haute société pas dégueu Elite l'élite
de la société oui
[Applaudissements]
serveur
là franchement
[Musique]
je serai surpris qui est pas un
restaurant ou un café qui cherche pas
[Musique]
on est où là c'est un restaurant oui
c'est sûr oui c'est sûr
et là en fait c'est une décharge
publique
[Musique]
[Rires]
et le chef nous nous a dit que c'était
une décharge quoi non j'ai pas envie de
rigoler là-dessus j'ai une petite vue
sur mon câlinque en train de griller
[Musique]
quand même principalement sur ta femme
oui mais ça je l'ai souvent par contre
le calamar qui grille je l'ai pas
souvent
[Musique]
et bon appétit bien sûr
j'ai plus peur de ma femme qui
m'engueule pour le bordel que le chef
tu ris non on sait c'est une question
tabou mais on a quand même voulu vous la
poser combien est-ce que vous gagnez par
mois
je sais pas si j'ai envie de le dire en
fait au revoir
[Rires]
2900 euros
1288 précisément 1800 euros alors c'est
plus ou c'est moins que la moyenne plus
ben moi du coup dans la moyenne
[Musique]
d'après les dernières données de l'INSEE
le salaire moyen en France s'élève à
2500 € net dans le secteur privé
2380 dans le public les 40 les sexes se
réduit mais restent élevés dans les
métiers du privé une femme gagnant
moyenne près de 400 euros de moins qu'un
homme en équivalent en temps plein
[Musique]
pas donné si on me rendait la monnaie
c'est pas
Mia mais attention le salaire moyen peut
s'avérer trompeur jetons un œil au
salaire médian la moitié des Français
gagne moins de 1837 euros l'autre moitié
gagne plus et 10 % des travailleurs
empochent plus de 4000 euros nettement
Suède et même 9500 € pour 1% d'entre
nous je possède des thunes je suis à
l'aise financièrement je ne me plains
pas non les affaires marchands en ce
moment je ne vois pas comment un garçon
de plage à Monaco à Marseille ou encore
soit en Martinique travailler rêve qu'un
pantalon et je trouve que le bermuda est
requis devrait être limite obligatoire
pour eux et pour tout le monde mais j'ai
pas comment Olivier de même peut venir
en bermuda ou Alain travailler ici ou
Charles mais on les voit pas
regardé
qui m'a envoyé des photos sur des des
messages sur mes pieds que voir mes
pieds qui veulent me de l'argent contre
des photos de mes pieds on voit tout ou
quoi